[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a europa hoy el
programa de actualidad europea de france
24 en español yo soy esther herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en bruselas
es un placer saludarles arrancamos esta
segunda temporada en un programa que
abordamos las consecuencias de la guerra
en ucrania seis meses después de que
estallara el conflicto que ha pasado en
este tiempo que puede ocurrir en un
conflicto que se prevé largo antes de
pasar al debate hacemos un breve repaso
a estos seis meses que han cambiado a
europa y al mundo
en la madrugada del pasado 24 de febrero
rusia invadió a ucrania una ex república
soviética que había mantenido en los
últimos años complicadas relaciones con
su país vecino
especialmente desde que moscú anexionar
a la península de crimea en 2014 y
decidiera apoyar a fuerzas separatistas
en la región del donbass en el este del
país lo que se preveía como una guerra
corta se ha alargado en el tiempo las
fuerzas rusas no tomaron la capital kiev
pero en localidades cercanas como butch
a oír ping se han reportado masacres
contra la población civil que podrían
constituir crímenes de guerra tras ello
el gobierno ruso anunció que se
concentraría en tomar el sur y este del
país cayeron grandes ciudades como
mariupol y gerson donde ahora el
gobierno ucraniano lado recientemente
una ofensiva mientras la unión europea
aprobó seis paquetes de sanciones
durante este tiempo contra rusia que no
sólo han tenido un impacto en la
economía del país también en la europea
especialmente a causa del aumento de los
precios y del petróleo la pregunta es
cuánto tiempo puede durar un conflicto
que marca la historia actual y para
analizar estos seis meses de conflicto
contamos con los eurodiputados del grupo
de los verdes/alianza libre europea
jordi solé bienvenidos yard y muchas
gracias muchas gracias a usted y también
contamos con el eurodiputado de renovar
europa javier nart bienvenido javier
agradecido a muchas gracias a los dos
por estar aquí de nuevo vamos a arrancar
primero analizando estos seis meses de
conflicto javier vemos que se está
alargando esta guerra
podría pasar que se convierta en un
conflicto que se congele que se quede
enquistado en esta guerra de desgaste
que estamos viendo ahora el propósito de
putin cuando empezó la guerra era
colocar un régimen títere en kiev que
está a 140 km de la frontera rusa y a
120 de la frontera bielorrusa donde
había fuerzas no lo han conseguido
y lo que ha demostrado el ejército ruso
es una absoluta incompetencia para
vencer a un ejército inferior en este
momento la situación es que rusia no
puede ganar pero tampoco puede ni debe
perder este es el problema ni ucrania
puede ganar ni rusia puede perder que
puede resultar esto en una guerra
relativamente larga con avances muy
cortos rusos como se está produciendo en
el arco del donets siguen avanzando muy
escasamente esto es un fracaso
descomunal para un ejército técnicamente
aparentemente muy superior pero no van a
cejar porque no pueden perder la faz es
una guerra que tiene un compromiso final
y que tardará en producirse
jordi como como estamos viendo es un
conflicto que se prevé largo estás de
acuerdo con javier si desgraciadamente
tengo que decir que estoy de acuerdo
porque esto se está convirtiendo en una
guerra de trincheras estamos viendo que
en estos días hay una contraofensiva por
parte del ejército de ucrania pero
parece que los avances son muy muy muy
lentos y es difícil ver
un fin un final de esta guerra a corto
plazo porque efectivamente
rusia no se puede permitir
salir perdiendo de esta guerra pero
ucrania tampoco va a dejar va a dejarse
ganar y entonces aunque estamos viendo
un apoyo masivo sobre todo del mundo
occidental a ucrania bueno enfrente
tiene a rusia que también es una
superpotencia y aunque han cometido
errores flagrantes desde el punto de
vista de estrategia militar pues siguen
teniendo uno de los ejércitos más
grandes del mundo entonces estamos en
una especie de situación de tablas que a
mí se me hace muy difícil pensar cómo
vamos a salir de aquí justamente asecho
y tapia a esta ayuda de occidente vemos
que se está alargando esta guerra como
comentamos es incontable la ayuda
europea se ha ayudado masivamente a
ucrania
ninguna ayuda es inagotable porque los
recursos por definición son finitos por
lo tanto tienen tienen un límite es
verdad que la unión europea ha puesto
encima de la mesa mucha mucha ayuda de
muchos tipos no solo
a militar también humanitaria financiera
etcétera y esto hay que ponerlo
encima de la mesa en el debate en el
sentido de hasta cuándo se va a poder
seguir ayudando en una situación digamos
donde en la unión europea' hay unas
problemáticas
acuciantes y que en fin que la gente las
familias las empresas pues tienen cada
día más dificultades para poder pagar
sus facturas no entonces veremos hasta
cuánto es decir el compromiso político
yo entiendo que este es para a largo
plazo digamos pero el compromiso
financiero yo no sé hasta qué punto
podrá ser sostenible en el tiempo mira
en un conflicto bélico y que considerar
no solamente la magnitud militar cuántos
carros de combate y cuántos aviones
cuántos soldados cuántos cañones es la
capacidad de resistencia esa palabra
nueva que se llama resiliencia eso es
fundamental entonces la afectación menor
pero con menos capacidad de aguante
resulta que es inferior aunque seas
mayor
numéricamente que la que tiene menos
pero más capacidad de aguante rusia
tiene históricamente una capacidad
ordinaria de sufrimiento sobre todo si
le manipulan los sentimientos sino los
pensamientos que es lo que está haciendo
putin qué es lo que hizo stalin en la
segunda guerra mundial cuando se dejó de
hablar de comunismo y se habló de la
defensa de la gran guerra patria hasta
el punto que las condecoraciones máximas
rusas excepto la estrella de unión
soviética de eros energética eran
generales y almirantes aristas bien este
es un tema el segundo es la guerra
económica a mí me sorprende la sorpresa
de europa que cuando comienza a hacer
maniobras y decisiones de
sanciones a rusia no entiende que pueda
haber también sanciones de rusia hacia
nosotros con independencia de la
justicia o la injusticia yo apoyo
absolutamente todo lo que se haga en
favor de ucrania porque nos estamos
jugando no a ucrania estamos jugándonos
nuestra credibilidad que es fundamental
ya la perdimos en crimea cuando
permitimos que se violaran los acordes
en helsinski y los de budapest donde
estados unidos-rusia perdón si rusia
francia y gran bretaña eran garantes y
la garantía se convirtió en música de
violines por lo tanto esto es
absolutamente fundamental y te reitero
como es posible que occidente no pensara
que la represalia que iba a hacer rusia
es un elemento fundamental que era el
gas y eso ha dado además un elemento y
concluyó
el paradigma de que la globalización
generaba la paz porque la
interdependencia con china con rusia con
rusia con el otro y todos juntos nos
daba una economía global de la que todos
éramos dependientes eso parecía que
evitaba o evitaría el que rusia rompiera
la baraja lo que no pensamos es en la
capacidad subjetiva y la historia es
objetiva como dice marx pero muy
subjetiva muy subjetiva de que putin
pegara un puñetazo en la mesa para
recuperar la estabilidad perdida tras la
explosión de rus y de la unión soviética
llamado a bielorrusia y los territorios
que entiende que son eslavos rusos y
también de la propia ucrania eso está
escrito en un artículo muy extenso de
historia que leí de putin en junio del
año pasado nadie se lo había leído
justamente hacías hincapié en estas
bueno también las consecuencias que está
teniendo para la unión europea
con el aumento de los precios del del
gas una inflación que marca récords va a
ser también capaz de la población de
aguantar estos niveles de presión porque
hemos visto ya manifestaciones
recientemente en república checa también
en italia
esta es la gran pregunta y esto está
ocurriendo casi inmediatamente después
de dos años de pandemia con todas las
consecuencias
digamos acumuladas económicas sociales
está por ver yo espero yo espero que sí
espero que la unión europea tenga una
respuesta a la altura de la situación
que es muy complicada veremos los
próximos días el paquete para reformar
el mercado eléctrico
poner impuestos a estos beneficios
caídos del cielo de las energéticas yo
creo que tiene que haber una respuesta
contundente en este sentido y sobre todo
poner recursos para aquellas familias
que más lo difícil lo tienen para poder
pagar pues las las facturas de los de
los suministros
también es cierto que las tensiones
inflacionistas ya venían de más lejos y
las tensiones en los precios de la
energía ya venían de antes de la
invasión rusa de ucrania pero esto
evidentemente ha acelerado y ha
multiplicado los los efectos yo espero
de la unión europea una respuesta que
esté a la altura como creo que fue la
respuesta a la pandemia con el next
generation y otras reacciones políticas
tenemos que estar a la altura porque si
no el malestar social
no se puede contener indefinidamente y
hay que encontrar salidas en la
dirección de justicia social y de
desarrollo
socioeconómico se está explicando
suficientemente bien que esto es una
consecuencia de la lucha por la
democracia como se está diciendo
el relato que es importante está muy
flojito en la unión europea' lo que se
habla es de macroeconomía que es
necesario pero no se habla de lo que
jordi bien es decir que es fundamental
tonal y si me parece impecablemente
correcto y es todo al final se convierte
en qué pasa con lo que me pasa y lo que
me pasa es lo que le está pasando y le
va a pasar a las personas con menos
recursos
la necesidad de una justicia social
profunda nos estamos quedando sin tiempo
pero quiero preguntar otra de estas
consecuencias de esta de esta guerra en
ucrania se ha dado el estatus de país
candidato a ucrania algo que se veía
prácticamente imposible era el pasado
adecuados jordi
a ver es un paso simbólico porque como
todo el mundo sabe un país no puede
acceder de un día para otro a la unión
europea tiene que
atender a unos requisitos que en la
mayoría de casos cuesta años no a
alcanzar yo creo que es simbólicamente
barra políticamente era el gesto
necesario pero tenemos que ser
conscientes de que el camino de ucrania
para llegar a entrar a la unión europea
sea un camino largo y dificultoso y
tenemos que evitar los dobles estándares
porque hay llamando a la puerta teníamos
otros estados que hacía mucho tiempo que
estaban o llamando la puerta o ya
negociando pero de una manera
absolutamente lenta si hay compromiso
con ucrania y entiendo la urgencia de
este compromiso tenemos que tener
también compromiso con aquellos países
que ya estaban en la cola y que también
están haciendo esfuerzos para ser un día
miembros de la unión europea así es
lamentablemente nos hemos quedado sin
tiempo muchas gracias a javier es jordi
a ustedes les esperamos en el próximo
programa de europa gracias por ver
france 24 en español
[Música]